hello Adele the 31 year old singer
showed off her dramatic weight loss at
jay-z and Beyonce's Oscar after-party
Sunday night Adele was a showstopper in
her leopard dress almost looking
unrecognizable in this photo a party
goer posted to Instagram the photo went
along with the caption that when
translated mentions that the singer
looked thin as a comma all this comes
just a few weeks after a fan claimed she
ran into Adele on vacation in Anguilla
and the singer admitted to shedding 100
pounds and it was really amazing the fan
went on to tell people magazine that she
seemed so happy and looked amazing
one of the last pics Adele posted to
Instagram was this one just before
Christmas showing off her figure in a
silk black dress and oh yeah we can't
forget when she's stunned at Drake's
33rd birthday bash back in October
according to the musicians ex personal
trainer
Camilla goodest the incredible
transformation didn't just come from the
gym she looks amazing she changed her
lifestyle she change her diet Adele has
had a lot of change in her life over the
past year it's been a complete Rowland
she's split with her husband Simon
connect II last April and on her 31st
birthday in May she took to Instagram to
talk about her resolution she captioned
this photo quote I've changed
drastically in the last couple years and
I'm still changing and that's okay
adding quotes learning to really truly
love yourself is it and I've only just
realized that that is more than enough
[Music]